what's going on guys today we're gonna
descend into the murky world of reddit
threads and chat rooms and explore fan
theories is there any merit to them are
they a bunch of crap we'll find out and
we have a couple cool dudes talk about
it with first
he's one of the schmoes from schmoes
know and one of the hosts of the Jedi
Council Kristian harloff and he's the
writer of honest trailers and the host
of doesn't hold up Spencer Gilbert
before we dive right in what do you
think about fan theories in general are
they did you hate them or is it part of
what we love about this stuff I think
they're really fun it's great for re
watching a movie with the fan theory in
mind but none of them are real let's be
honest no one's that smart let's dive
into our first one Batman V Superman
first off this fan theory it's sprawling
it's everywhere and it's a little
bananas but follow me
they say it's part of the Nolan verse
the three Dark Knight movies did not
stop Christian Bale is still Batman what
has been Affleck then Ben Affleck is
Deathstroke they're saying and there are
little Easter eggs and the trailers that
say Oh Bruce Wayne couldn't run into the
the rubble of Metropolis and the all the
smoke and everything he'd die but
Deathstroke could because he's a
metahuman and they're saying that Joseph
gordon-levitt's character john blake is
actually the joker recast with Jared
Leto a lot of stuff going on here
imagine how confusing it would be if
you're a general audience member and you
go in and Christian Bale shows up and
then Ben Affleck says I'm Deathstroke
I'm not Batman this is a movie that
already has Wonder Woman that already
has lex luthor that already has superman
i mean i would love it but that would be
the most bananas movie of all time
there's no way that this happening it's
taking people a while to go wait a
minute Ben Apple is gonna be Batman and
then you said no well he's not he's
actually that stroke and then you try to
tie it into this what no one portrayed
this very realistic world of Gotham oh
one other thing with this theory they're
saying Batman V Superman and Roman
numeral v bet that's the fifth one Wow
yeah I don't know about so on a scale of
one to ten with one being no way and ten
being like ah that's plausible tinfoil
bat hat
that's a one okay i won can I go point
five point five for the record that is
less than one yeah okay so yeah we're
calling BS on that yeah
oh this next one another doozy Jar Jar
Binks Sith Lord dot what he influenced
the Emperor he was a skilled Jedi he
used mind tricks and he used this
fighting style that was like very
similar to like Jackie Chan's drunken
master also similar to minstrel acts
nineteen twenties
some people say he's an insulting
character yes but is Jar Jar like a dark
genius of these movies if this was true
and you found out that Jar Jar Binks was
a villain inhabitance in the force
awakens in a month from now riots this
would be bigger than Kaiser Soze this be
bigger than the ending of seven if the
twist of Jar Jar being a Sith Lord is
true it's the big it's the greatest
trick the devil ever pulled
there was slowdown footage of people
saying things in the prequels and then
you see jar jar's mouth moving like he's
doing a Jedi mind trick on them if Jar
Jar is the inverse of Yoda
yeah Yoda is this kind of goofy little
puppet thing that turns out to be this
great Jedi Master Jar Jar is this goofy
CGI thing that turns out to be this
horrible Sith Lord one maybe yeah and
when you think about it Jar Jar Binks is
the one that practically crowned the
Emperor he didn't he gave him the powers
but Palpatine again coerced him into
doing that
the theory was very already it was very
smart it's crazy
I want to believe Jar Jar I want to
believe I'm really x-files on this stage
he said he was gonna kill him JJ said he
was gonna put his bones in the desert so
we could see it it's not having that
bones are gonna be summer look for those
so on a scale of one to ten I'm going to
the Jedi Council first one one I'm
giving this a fox mulder three Wow okay
okay next let's dive into the Harry
Potter universe this theory posits that
Neville Longbottom the inept peer of
Harry Potter is actually the chosen one
so there's a prophecy that lists what it
requires to be the chosen one
and Neville qualifies for all of
them as does Harry Potter well I hate to
quote scripture at you but the book it
says um that he will be marked by the
Dark Lord yes part of the prophecy Harry
Potter's got a big old lightning bolt
tattoo on his forehead
some people say that Voldemort torturing
nevels parents psychologically scarred
and marked him come on man I mean
there's a that is I'm sorry for Neville
I'm sorry for the Longbottom's but Harry
Potter has a lightning bolt on his eye
if you look at it you can the guy makes
a good case occasionally we'll wait a
minute he is the one who kind of hits uh
Baltimore in the sweet spot they even
said that that a Dumbledore shifted the
focus onto Harry so we didn't get a lot
of spotlight on Neville so he could do
what he had to do but yeah it's a Terry
Potter movie yeah and we saw him get old
with kids on a scale of one to ten uh
what's the possibility of this being
real I'll give it a three okay three
okay three
Wingardium like a Joe at one it blows my
mind that you gave the charge or what a
three that's one Spectre just came out
here's a theory that James Bond is only
a code name
so each actor Sean Connery Roger Moore
Timothy Dalton etc it's not rebooting
the franchise it's just an another agent
taking the bond mantel in mi6 whoever
achieves double-oh-seven status is now
the James Bond I can I can dig this
theory because each one it doesn't take
place in like the 60s or the 70s
takes place in the time period supposed
to take place and it's interesting to
bees even though it's the same kind of
guy where they're smooth the womanizer
there's a particular model of dude that
the program looks for yeah it makes a
lot of sense that a secret agent
wouldn't use his real name every time
he's out on a mission um also you have
examples of people like em and people
like Q who go by code names and change
all the time in the James Bond universe
Judy Dench she was M for Brosnan and
Craig so that lends itself to what we're
talking about the fly in the ointment is
Skyfall where he went back to his home
alone trap house and
you saw pictures of his family now the
only way around that is if you think
that Skyfall is where they take the new
James Bond to brainwash them into
thinking that they've assumed the
identity of James Bond if they
programmed every Bond to be like a
killing machine do they also program him
to be a womanizer girlfriend it's kind
of crazy personally yeah I'm with
Christiane I would love it if this was
the truth so let's talk about this let's
rate it Christian scale one to ten four
okay okay uh I'm gonna go with a another
five because you can read it that way if
you uh Bend yourself into shape a lot of
people have talked about the ending of
Inception does the top fall does it keep
spinning what happens reality dream this
fan theory contends that the top is not
actually Leo's totem it's actually his
wedding ring he has his wedding ring in
dreams he does not have it in reality in
the final scene of the film he doesn't
have it so it's real he's come home to
his children it makes a lot of sense
because from what I understand the totem
is supposed to be something that only
you know about and only you can tell the
difference I think we all know what it
looks like when a top falls over yeah so
that would be a really bad totem that
everyone could look at me like oh you're
in a dream you're not in a dream the
wedding ring thing is really smart and
it would fit with his character being
like the best dream hacker I don't know
what he is being the best at what he
does yes he would have a red herring
like that i 100% buy into this theory
and because this is different from those
stuff that we're talking about to this
is Christopher Nolan going come on try
to figure this out
no one's never want talk about it
doesn't say yes or no and you went he's
been asked about this thing too he
doesn't deny it
he just says watch me Christopher
Nolan's one of those guys he's so
detail-oriented that he could pull the
wool over us and get something in there
like that
okay so let's rate this one scale of one
to ten Christian I'm gonna do it ten I'm
going I know in 10 I think this is a
diluted I'll go nine blahs just to give
myself a little wiggle room you know
what I love it and if a bookcase can be
another dimension the wedding ring
can be the total oh I love this one this
one's so stupid okay Joey Dave coulier's
character from Full House is the father
of all the children you are the father
Bob Saget has dark hair his wife who
deceased who we see in like one video
clip has light hair all the kids have
light hair 12% chance that all the kids
could have light hair who has light hair
Dave coulier's character Joey Joey is
Bob Saget's childhood friend why would
he devote eight years of his life to
helping his childhood friend raise his
kids he is that little going on it only
makes sense that Joey is the father of
all the kids in that house all the
Tanner kids I'll say because he's you
because he could do a lot of impressions
and impressions were huge in the 80s cut
it out this is absolutely he would he
could just pull out that Muppet baby
animal impression any time he wanted to
he was scoring chicks I buy it he's got
like that great that great mullet you
can't resist this is a guy that uh who
could resist a guy in a mullet in a
hockey jersey he's scored Alanis
Morisette exact chord right that's the
real fan theories he is the subject of
the song you ought to know yeah those
kids look nothing like Bob Saget it's a
ten out of ten let me take it one more
level let me inception this that much
more Uncle Jesse got married and had
twins those twins both had blond hair
Uncle Jesse and his wife dark hair Dave
Coulier also had sex with uncle Jesse's
wife a handful her house they're gonna
explain all of this yes and he's not
wearing a wedding ring in any of the
scenes so could we all just give this
tens and move on yes great
Wow so what do we leave out what's a fan
theory that we're missing his group
really Thanos is jaws in the Finding
Nemo universe tell us in the comments
section below the best answer the most
fun answer we're gonna send you a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank these
two dudes Kristian harloff schmoes no
collider Jedi Council I thank you for
being here sir thank you very much I'm
Ariel and Spencer Gilbert tell us about
your new show real quick oh man well you
know there's some movies
that let's be real we're never gonna get
around to doing honest trailer for but I
still want to watch demolition man so I
am bringing on guests we're watching our
favorite movies that we had as a kid
seeing if they hold up I hope you look
absolutely I would love to and Spencer
where exactly could we find that screen
junkies poo which is French for plus
week screen junkies plus um it's already
dropped get on board
join the party it's a good time three
month free trial and screen junkies calm
heck yeah
do it now I want to thank you for
watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit us all up
on Twitter bye bye
when the rock was taking me through the
doors I didn't know what was happening
what I really thought in my head was oh
hey they're gonna prank me and there's
going to be a surprise pizza party